you both play the same character in the
film younger versions of each other and
your sisters in real life so what was it
like playing each other on the big
screen
well it was it was a really natural kind
of job because by doing my scene she did
her team's it was really you know just
you're not the same person you are when
you're 10 as you are in your twenties so
like we would be with different
characters really of the same person so
cool to have a Jeremy and Toby also
having you know the sibling thing so it
will felt very natural together it's
just a second sir you kind of coordinate
anything as well just to keep a maybe a
consistency so as you say people do
change don't they at those ages but to
have any other note idiosyncrasies or
anything like that are you carry through
um I don't I we're really similar anyway
so I think that that would have just
hopefully come across I haven't seen it
so I don't know if we've made something
totally different to each other um but
she's the thing about videos she's
steadfast she's totally this she's loyal
she's the same really it she doesn't she
doesn't change which is what happened to
excite I think it would have been wrong
to have changed dramatically in the film
great run the show sheet there that gosh
you weren't actually on set of course
playing that same carriage at different
age there any time weren't you was a
little bit strange so playing the
character but not being together at all
it was it's when you know your sisters
doing a job or even a friend is doing a
job when you're not there you feel like
it you want to be there so I felt a bit
like I wanted to kind of spy on her and
see what she was doing but but no I just
got like my mum sent me photos and stuff
and I cried everybody told me that you
know it was amazing and so you know I
just tried to either be good as well
Jesse and of course that you've had
experience as another British
institution haven't you Harry Potter has
it compared moving on to great
expectations of course you've got a few
of the same cars haven't you on this
film as you did with Harry Potter I know
and it was it felt very
if what was interesting is it was kind
of my first film as an as an actress as
an adult so to be in a film with with
actors who had been on a previous summer
I wasn't it was it was a strange thing
really but it was nice to see that these
actors it was a job you know and so they
had been and hope was that was a job but
this is a job just because it's you know
a lot of the same artistic people don't
see each other really see you they might
have not even crossed paths of each
other in Harry Potter and I didn't
really see idly speed ahead and her and
I with her so it was it even though it
on paper and looks like that it it's not
but it's still nice to be on the same
page as there and tell me what was it
like working with Mike Newell's he said
you're great director isn't he yeah and
he's just he's he's done stuff so like
you feel you're safe with him use he
knows what he's doing you know the lingo
is so it was so great it was he was he
felt strong and capable hands
how about you theory he's just the
biggest personality will ever meet he
made everything feel so not scary I mean
I've never done anything like this so I
mean just I'm the luckiest to be able to
work with him absolutely
what sort of memories are gonna take
away with you from the set do you think
why style quite a lot of stuff so I'll
be fine
oh god I just mouths I took a hair a bit
Henry Bonham Carter's hands so
definitely remember that guys are you
gonna be up to nine and well I might and
I do
I'd use comedy things on my own which is
quite scary but yeah just we'll see what
and I use BB for a lot of it so it
continues how about you baby well I'm at
school so I mean this is just the most
amazing kind of thing to be involved in
hopefully it's about your firm JK
Rowling's next works made into a big
film would you like to be an actor thing
and what kind of road you liking it
oh gosh I need to read it first definite
need to read it I'm gonna get on that
yeah well do you think there's a role
for me I think I think you've got a
demand on how are you okay oh I'll get
on that
you